- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Bonjour à tous.
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La première question
va être posée
par madame
Béatrice Descamps
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Béatrice Descamps:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
4 millions, c'est le nombre
de Français atteints
de diabète.
Selon un dernier rapport,
ils seront 500.000
de plus à la fin
de ce quinquennat.
Les chiffres
sont alarmants
et en cette Journée
mondiale du diabète,
je souhaite porter
la voix de ces patients
qui sont de réels acteurs
de leur maladie.
Vous le savez,
les Français atteints
de diabète doivent
s'astreindre
dès leur diagnostic
à modifier
leurs habitudes de vie,
et une large proportion d'entre
eux doivent
surveiller eux-mêmes
leur taux de glycémie.
Selon les recommandations
de la Haute Autorité
de Santé, datées de 2011,
un patient diabétique
est tenu de se piquer
une dizaine
de fois par jour
pour surveiller
sa glycémie.
Or cette recommandation
qui doit guider
les professionnels
de santé
dans la prise
en charge des patients
est obsolète et a 10
ans de retard.
Depuis une dizaine d'années,
les traitements,
la gestion de la maladie
et notamment
les méthodes
de surveillance glycémique
ont considérablement évolué.
Monsieur le ministre,
l'innovation santé
est prolifique.
C'est le cas
pour le diabète
et nous nous en réjouissons.
Mais sans traduction
par nos politiques
de santé,
cette innovation
ne trouvera pas sa place
auprès
des patients.
Il est temps
de faire en sorte
que les recommandations
de prise
en charge évoluent
pour refléter
les nouvelles options
diagnostiques
et thérapeutiques,
mais aussi l'implication
de l'ensemble
des professionnels
de santé autour de médecins
généralistes
dans la gestion
quotidienne des patients.
Ma question est simple:
quand la Haute Autorité
de Santé mettra-t-elle à jour
ses recommandations
au profit de la prise
en charge
des différents diabètes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Madame la députée,
je ne pratique pas
les questions
au gouvernement
depuis longtemps,
mais je sais qu'il est d'usage
de remercier
la personne qui vous pose
la question.
Je voudrais vous remercier
très sincèrement
de poser et de mettre
en lumière
ce sujet majeur
en cette Journée mondiale
du diabète,
Journée mondiale
depuis 1991.
Vous l'avez dit,
4 millions de nos concitoyens
sont touchés par le diabète.
On a tendance
à banaliser
ce que ça signifie,
vous l'avez
très bien dit.
Le diabète, c'est vivre
tous les jours
avec la pathologie,
devoir adapter
son traitement, devoir se suivre.
Il est donc très important
aujourd'hui
de saluer et de penser
aux patients.
C'est d'autant
plus important
que la crise du Covid
nous a montré
à quel point le diabète
est une pathologie
qui a des conséquences
systémiques,
et dans la surmortalité
liée au Covid,
on a retrouvé beaucoup
de patients diabétiques.
Je voudrais souligner
que beaucoup
de progrès ont été
effectués, notamment,
je crois que la lutte
contre la sédentarité
et l'activité physique
sont des axes forts
contre le diabète.
Nous avons aussi
progressé en matière
de télésurveillance à domicile.
C'est un point
très important
pour la qualité de vie du patient.
Mais je crois,
et vous le dites
très bien,
que nous devons
être à la hauteur
et aller à la vitesse
des innovations thérapeutiques.
Les patients sont prêts
à être des acteurs
de leur propre santé.
Les patients
diabétiques,
ce sont sans doute
les mieux armés
pour le faire.
Nous allons les accompagner
encore plus, notamment
dans les dispositifs
de télésurveillance
et dans le financement
de nouveaux traitements.
Je vous confirme également
que la Haute Autorité
de Santé, j'ai échangé
avec son président
il y a quelques jours,
produira
dans les prochains mois
les recommandations
pour le diabète
de type 2 pour adapter
les recommandations
faites il y a 10 ans.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La prochaine question
va être posée
par madame Pascale Bordes
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Pascale Bordes:
Madame la présidente,
chers collègues,
madame la Première ministre,
la montée des actes
antisémites,
des agressions
contre nos compatriotes juifs,
les pogroms auxquels
nous avons assisté
en Israël nous rappellent
que l'ignominie
des hommes,
les idéologies de haine
sont prêtes à surgir
dès que nous baissons
la garde,
dès que la défense
du bien pris
devant la faiblesse,
dès que le souci de l'avenir cède.
En faisant le choix
inconsidéré de faire entrer
en France sans discernement
ni contrôle
des millions d'immigrés,
la classe politique
a aussi fait entrer et a même
organisé l'entrée
dans notre pays de gens
prosélytes porteurs
d'une idéologie sanguinaire.
Que l'on soit bien
clairs,
je ne confonds pas
les musulmans
qui pratiquent leur religion
de manière paisible
et fraternelle
avec les islamistes.
De la même
manière,
je ne confonds pas
les Palestiniens
avec le Hamas qui s'en sert
comme boucliers humains.
Face au fléau
de l'antisémitisme,
le pays a opposé,
par une manifestation unitaire
et digne dont chacun
doit se féliciter,
la démonstration
de sa réprobation absolue face
à ce qui touche
à l'essentiel,
toute division devient un acte
de complicité objective.
Pour autant,
parce que nous le devons
à l'histoire
et aux victimes
de cette barbarie,
mais aussi pour l'avenir
parce que nous le devons
à nos enfants,
les protestations
aussi éplorées
que fortes soient-elles
ne suffisent pas.
Elles ne feront reculer
aucun fanatique,
aucun prêcheur de haine,
aucun idiot utile
de l'islamisme.
Pourtant, force
est de constater,
au vu des dernières
déclarations
de membres
du gouvernement
ou de la majorité,
que vous n'osez
même pas désigner
l'idéologie qui sous-tend
la haine antisémitisme.
On ne combat pas
une menace
quand on est incapable
d'en parler.
Qu'allez-vous faire
pour combattre l'islamisme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Olivier Véran, ministre
en charge du Renouveau
démocratique
et porte-parole du gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran:
Madame la présidente,
madame la députée
Pascale Bordes,
Coulibaly, Mohamed Merah
et de nombreux autres djihadistes
ont commis des attentats
antisémites
sur notre sol au nom
de l'idéologie islamiste,
et cela, personne ne le nie.
Le gouvernement lutte
avec acharnement...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Habib!
Encore une fois
et je vous rappelle
à l'ordre!
- Olivier Véran:
Le gouvernement lutte
avec détermination
contre le fanatisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Habib!
Monsieur le ministre.
- Olivier Véran:
Le gouvernement lutte
avec détermination
contre le radicalisme islamiste
qui tue,
contre le radicalisme
islamiste qui commet
des actes antisémites.
Vous avez commencé
par poser une question
sur l'antisémitisme
et vous terminez
par la lutte contre l'islamisme.
En réalité,
le gouvernement lutte
avec détermination
contre toutes les formes
d'antisémitisme,
lutte
contre toutes les idéologies
mortifères
qui visent à diviser
les Français
les uns
contre les autres,
toutes les idéologies,
d'où
qu'elles viennent,
qui mettent en insécurité
nos concitoyens juifs.
Il y en a, hélas,
en dehors du cadre
de l'islam.
Nous ne les négligeons pas.
Ce que de nombreux Français
ont été nombreux
à dire dans de nombreuses
villes
de France dimanche,
c'est que l'antisémitisme,
les antisémitismes,
toutes les formes d'antisémitisme
qui gangrènent
notre société
n'ont pas leur place en France.
Croyez en notre détermination
pour lutter
contre cela.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît,
un peu de silence.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Sylvain Maillard.
- Sylvain Maillard: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
dimanche dernier,
ce sont plus de 180.000 personnes
qui ont défilé dans les rues
de 70 villes partout
en France.
Elles ont marché
pour la République
et contre l'antisémitisme.
Avec le président du Sénat,
je veux saluer
votre appel, madame la présidente.
Applaudissements
...
Ces marches ont été,
pour reprendre
les mots du président
de la République,
un motif d'espérance.
Ce soulèvement
de la nation
est celui
de tout un peuple face
à la haine antisémite.
L'antisémitisme,
ce n'est pas qu'un chiffre
horrible que l'on égrène,
1518 actes rien qu'en
un mois.
Ce sont des Français
et des Françaises,
comme vous,
comme moi, qui vivent
dans la terreur du fait
de leur confession.
C'est Max, 20 ans,
qui, en entrant
à l'université,
a le nez cassé
parce qu'il est juif.
C'est Alain,
qui porte une kippa
et sur qui on crache
le genou à terre.
C'est Samuel qui,
depuis 30 ans, n'est
plus allé dans son université
de médecine
après avoir reçu
des insultes
et des coups.
C'est Sarah,
dont le fils de 8 ans
a remis des couches la nuit
par peur d'aller
à l'école.
Je tiens aujourd'hui
à remercier
nos policiers
et nos militaires qui,
chaque jour, s'assurent
de leur sécurité.
Mais aucun citoyen
français ne devrait
avoir à vivre
cela car la haine
des juifs, c'est le signe
du délitement
de notre République,
tout comme les faux-nez
d'antisémitisme.
Comment mettre un terme
à cette dangereuse recrudescence
de l'antisémitisme
dans notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président
Sylvain Maillard,
depuis le 7 octobre
et l'attaque terroriste
du Hamas contre Israël,
nous assistons
à une augmentation
sans précédent
des actes antisémites
dans notre pays.
En un mois,
ce sont plus de 1500 actes
qui ont été constatés.
C'est plus que sur une année
entière.
Les Français de confession
juive vivent
dans l'angoisse.
C'est grave, c'est inadmissible
dans la République
où personne ne doit
être inquiété en raison
de ses croyances.
Monsieur le président,
face à ces actes,
il y a d'abord
notre action résolue.
Nous avons passé des consignes
de vigilance extrême
aux préfets.
Nos forces de l'ordre,
les militaires
de l'opération Sentinelle
sont mobilisés
pour assurer la sécurité
des lieux sensibles,
en particulier
les lieux de culte
ou les écoles.
Nous avons également
demandé
la plus grande
fermeté aux parquets.
Des enquêtes sont lancées.
Des condamnations
sont prononcées,
jusqu'à 18 mois dans certains cas.
Mais monsieur le président
Sylvain Maillard,
vous avez raison
de le dire, face
à l'antisémitisme,
une réaction unanime
et sans ambiguïté
est indispensable.
Lutter
contre l'antisémitisme,
c'est l'affaire de tous.
S'en prendre
à une personne
parce qu'elle est juive,
c'est s'en prendre
à la République.
Notre devoir,
c'est de lutter
contre toutes les haines.
Monsieur le président
Maillard, dimanche,
à l'initiative de la présidente
Yaël Braun-Pivet,
que je tiens à saluer,
et à celle
du président
du Sénat Gérard Larcher,
la France a été
au rendez-vous
pour dire non
à l'antisémitisme
et pour défendre
avec force les valeurs
de la République.
Applaudissements
Je ne reviendrai pas
sur ceux qui croient pouvoir faire
oublier d'où ils viennent.
Je ne reviendrai pas
non plus sur l'attitude
de ceux qui refusent
de marcher
contre l'antisémitisme
et qui ont tenté
de salir cette marche à coups
de mensonges indignes.
Je n'ai pas besoin
d'en dire
plus car les Français
leur ont répondu.
Ils ont répondu en marchant,
très nombreux,
contre toutes les haines.
Ils ont répondu
dans l'unité au-delà
des opinions et des croyances.
Ils ont répondu
avec dignité, clarté
et dans le rassemblement.
Ensemble,
nous l'avons affirmé,
nous combattrons
l'antisémitisme jusqu'au bout.
La haine n'a pas sa place
dans la République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Thibault Bazin
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Thibault Bazin: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, le logement
est en crise
et vos décisions
y ont contribué.
Après avoir, en 2018,
quasiment supprimé l'APL
et divisé par deux le prêt
à taux zéro
pour de nombreuses
communes, votre bilan
est catastrophique.
En 2011, près de 351.000 PTZ
ont été accordés.
Quand on regarde
dans le détail
ce que vous prévoyez,
cela ressemble
à une supercherie.
Vous clamez que vos mesures
permettront
à 6 millions de foyers
supplémentaires d'accéder
au PTZ, mais dans les faits,
la Fédération bancaire française
estime qu'au maximum,
15.000 nouveaux ménages
bénéficieront
de l'augmentation
des plafonds de ressources.
On est loin des 6 millions.
Le PTZ ne pourra
financer que 20%
de l'achat pour ces nouveaux
ménages éligibles,
contre 40% auparavant.
Vous voulez aussi exclure du PTZ
l'achat d'une maison neuve,
ce qui revient,
de facto, à exclure
plus d'un tiers
des anciens bénéficiaires
du PTZ.
Au final,
on risque
d'avoir encore moins d'excédent.
Vous affirmez avec fierté
ajouter 209 communes
au dispositif,
mais la réalité,
c'est qu'avec
ces modifications,
93% des communes verront
leurs habitants privés
de toute aide
pour la construction
de leur résidence principale.
Les fractures
territoriales
vont encore s'aggraver.
Quand allez-vous
enfin rétablir
une politique
de véritable soutien
à l'accession à la propriété
sur l'ensemble
du territoire?
Quand allez-vous enfin
répondre à l'aspiration
des Français qui veulent
devenir propriétaires
de leur maison?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Clément Beaune,
ministre en charge des Transports.
- Clément Beaune:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député Bazin...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Un peu de silence,
s'il vous plaît.
Le gouvernement choisit
sa représentation.
- Clément Beaune:
Je vois que ça suscite
un peu d'émotion.
Je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence
du ministre
du Logement,
qui est dans une réunion
européenne
et ne pouvait pas être présent
cet après-midi.
Vous avez raison,
nous sommes face
à une grave crise
du logement
qui ne concerne pas
que notre pays
et sur laquelle
le gouvernement
est mobilisé
avec de nombreuses réponses.
D'abord, sur les causes
de cette crise,
il faut être précis,
elle est liée
à la multiplication
par trois des taux d'intérêt.
Cela impacte le pouvoir
d'achat immobilier
des Français.
Elle est liée aussi
à des contraintes d'offres,
la hausse des coûts
de construction,
le prix du foncier
qui est plus élevé
et des contraintes
administratives,
y compris locales,
qui se cumulent
et ne permettent pas
de réduire
les prix pour les adapter
à cette crise.
Nous avons multiplié
les réponses
pour que nous soyons
capables de répondre
aux différents facteurs
de cette crise.
L'objectif est clair:
proposer des logements
de qualité, abordables
et à proximité
des lieux d'emploi.
Cela suppose aussi
une adaptation
des collectivités
locales auxquelles
le gouvernement entend confier
de nouveaux moyens
et de nouvelles
responsabilités
dans le cadre d'une loi
de décentralisation
qui sera débattue
ici même en 2024.
A court terme,
le gouvernement agit
pour développer le logement
locatif intermédiaire,
pour élargir le prêt
à taux zéro,
et le ministre
continue à travailler
sur ce dispositif.
Vous avez cité
un certain nombre
de sujets.
Nous facilitons aussi
l'accès au crédit.
Nous augmentons par ailleurs
la capacité d'investissement
des bailleurs sociaux.
C'est le sens du document
qui a été signé
avec les HLM.
Face à la multiplicité
des causes
de la crise, nous devons
avoir des réponses multiples
et nous devons travailler
sur la question
des compétences
avec les collectivités locales.
- Thibault Bazin:
Monsieur le ministre,
votre réponse
n'est pas à la hauteur
de la crise du logement
que connaît
notre pays.
Alors que les taux
d'intérêt augmentent,
il faut renforcer
le prêt à taux zéro
sur l'ensemble
du territoire,
et pas seulement sur certains
territoires privilégiés.
Il y a urgence à prendre
les mesures nécessaires
pour soutenir non
seulement l'accès
à la propriété,
mais aussi la rénovation
sur l'ensemble du territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Charles Larsonneur.
- Jean-Charles Larsonneur: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, près
de 15 jours après le passage
des tempêtes Ciaran
et Domingos,
nous sommes toujours
en situation d'urgence
en Bretagne.
5000 foyers sont encore privés
d'électricité
dans le Finistère.
J'adresse tout mon soutien
aux personnes plongées
dans le noir, le froid
et l'isolement.
J'exprime également
ma pleine solidarité
aux habitants du Nord
et du Pas-de-Calais,
confrontés à des crues
dévastatrices.
Un grand merci
à la préfecture du Finistère
pour ses points
quotidiens
avec les élus,
les maires placés
en première ligne,
à tous les personnels mobilisés,
y compris ceux venus en soutien
d'autres régions.
Nous commençons à peine
à chiffrer l'ampleur
des dégâts.
Tous les réseaux
d'électricité
sont touchés.
Les dégâts
sont considérables
sur les bâtiments publics
et dans l'agriculture.
Le retour à la normale
prendra du temps.
Néanmoins, nos concitoyens
ont un besoin
de visibilité
sur le rétablissement
de l'électricité.
L'état de catastrophe
naturelle
et le régime
des calamités agricoles
ne sont pas aisés
à activer
dans de telles circonstances.
Où en sommes-nous?
Pouvons-nous envisager
un complément
pour les collectivités
les plus touchées
en 2024?
Quels dispositifs
allez-vous mettre
en place en termes
de retour d'expérience
sur la résilience de nos réseaux?
Il a été difficile,
voire impossible
de contacter les maires
et les populations
durant plusieurs jours.
Faut-il multiplier
les exercices
de gestion de crise?
A long terme,
allons-nous débloquer
des moyens pour sécuriser
les réseaux
dans les régions
les plus exposées?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure:
Monsieur le député,
je veux d'abord vous dire
tout le soutien
du gouvernement
à la violence
de cette tempête
en Bretagne,
mais on est tous
solidaires également
des crues dans le Nord
et dans le Pas-de-Calais.
Les dommages causés
par les vents violents
sont couverts
par la garantie tempête
qui est prévue dans le code
des assurances.
Cette garantie permet
une indemnisation directe
par les assureurs
des biens sinistrés
des collectivités
territoriales
sans qu'une
déclaration préalable
de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
par les pouvoirs publics
soit nécessaire.
Le président de la République,
en déplacement
le 3 novembre
dans le Finistère,
s'est engagé
au déclenchement rapide
de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
et de celui de calamité
agricole partout
où on pourra le faire.
La réunion du comité catastrophe
naturelle s'est tenue
ce jour en tout début
d'après-midi.
Les arrêtés seront pris demain.
Cela concerne
tant les particuliers
que les collectivités
territoriales.
Au-delà du cadre assuranciel,
des mécanismes
de soutien spécifiques
sont mobilisables
par les collectivités.
Pour les dommages
aux équipements publics
non assurables,
elles peuvent se prévaloir
du régime de la dotation
de solidarité
et ainsi bénéficier
de crédits
pour leurs ouvrages d'art,
leurs infrastructures,
leurs parcs,
leurs jardins
ou leurs stations d'épuration.
Le gouvernement sera
également présent
aux côté des agriculteurs.
Il y a les dispositifs
de droit commun
de dégrèvement,
de taxes sur le foncier
non bâti et le report
de cotisations sociales.
Il y a aussi
l'indemnité nationale
en cas de perte
catastrophique de récolte.
Via le fonds d'aide
au relogement,
les collectivités
prenant en charge
le relogement d'urgence peuvent
bénéficier d'une aide
de 75% à 100% des dépenses.
Je veux saluer
une fois de plus ici
la mobilisation
exceptionnelle conjointe
du binôme préfets
et maires au service
de nos concitoyens.
- Jean-Charles
Larsonneur:
C'est très important
pour les habitants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Nathalie Oziol
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Nathalie Oziol:
Il y a cinq jours,
alors que l'on comptait
plus de 10.000 morts
à Gaza, Emmanuel
Macron a appelé
pour la première fois
à un cessez-le-feu.
Il a plus tard
ajouté qu'il n'y
a aucune raison
et aucune légitimité
à bombarder et tuer
des bébés, des femmes,
des personnes âgées.
Cet appel, bien que tardif,
était salutaire,
mais il lui a valu
d'être aussitôt accusé
de planter un couteau
dans le dos
de la communauté juive
et de frôler l'antisémitisme
sur la chaîne i24 News.
La diplomatie française
a aussi été prise
à partie par le CRIF.
Il s'est permis de demander
une clarification
de la position de la France.
Dimanche, ce qui devait
être une marche
contre l'antisémitisme
a été le lieu d'appel
au meurtre
contre La France Insoumise,
contre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
et contre le président
de la République.
Des journalistes
ont été agressés,
des militants
pour la paix en Palestine
ont été frappés.
Les musulmans ont été la cible
de propos racistes insupportables.
Pendant que le petit monde
politico-médiatique français
se gargarise de cette journée
désastreuse,
la presse étrangère
est sidérée
par le blanchiment
de l'extrême droite
qui a lieu en France
sur le dos
de la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme.
A La France Insoumise,
nous refusons
que soit rétrécie la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme,
contre le racisme
et contre l'extrême droite
qui en est le premier vecteur.
Nous refusons que soit encouragé
l'affrontement
des Françaises et des Français
de confession juive
et ceux de confession musulmane.
Chaque samedi, les marches
pour le cessez-le-feu
et pour la paix
sont une formidable démonstration
du peuple.
Condamnez-vous
les propos racistes
contre nos compatriotes musulmans?
Le ministère de l'Intérieur
va-t-il interdire
la ligue de défense juive?
Condamnez-vous
les propos tenus
contre le président
de la République?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna:
Madame la députée Oziol,
je voudrais
vous rappeler
que depuis le 7
octobre, la position
de la France
est constante
et elle est basée
sur nos principes.
Israël, victime d'attaques
terroristes abominables,
j'espère
que vous le reconnaissez,
a le droit de se défendre
et de protéger
sa population
contre le Hamas
et le devoir,
nous le disons,
de se défendre
dans le cadre du respect
du droit international,
et en particulier,
Israël doit faire
tout son possible
pour protéger
les populations civiles.
C'est une obligation
légale et morale.
Je le redis volontiers ici.
Il faut rappeler que,
de la même façon,
ce que fait le Hamas
en utilisant
des hôpitaux, des écoles
comme des rampes
de lancement
de roquettes, doit
être condamné.
En agissant ainsi,
le Hamas met sciemment
la population
palestinienne en péril.
Face à l'urgence
humanitaire,
qui est réelle,
la France a organisé
le 9 novembre une conférence
humanitaire internationale
pour la population civile de Gaza.
Outre le milliard
d'euros annoncé
grâce à cette conférence,
celle-ci
a permis d'acter
un consensus international
en faveur d'une
trêve immédiate
qui puisse garantir
que les aides parviennent
aux populations.
C'est un pas important et concret.
Puis, il faudra oeuvrer
à un cessez-le-feu.
Il faudra enfin restaurer
un horizon politique.
C'est une position
constante de la France
que de le rappeler.
La France n'a jamais oublié
que la seule solution viable,
c'est celle
de deux Etats vivant
en paix côte à côte.
Nous y travaillons
avec nos partenaires
et il est plus que temps
d'avancer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Jacqueline Maquet
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Jacqueline Maquet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargée
des Collectivités
territoriales
et de la Ruralité.
Je m'adresse à vous au nom
d'autres députés
dont les circonscriptions ont été
amplement touchées
par les inondations.
Ils sont retenus
par la visite du président
de la République.
"En quelques minutes,
il y avait 1,50 mètre d'eau
chez moi, c'est vraiment
une catastrophe.
J'ai pris une échelle
pour monter
sur mon toit
car l'eau est montée
très vite.
Mes animaux vont mourir.
J'ai peur de mourir."
Ce sont des mots
d'habitants
qui ont vu leur maison
être prise
par les eaux.
Des centaines de familles
se sont retrouvées sinistrées.
Des milliers de personnes
ont été déplacées.
Des centaines de logements
ont été inondés.
Les entreprises sont à l'arrêt.
Des bâtiments publics
ont été fragilisés.
Ces inondations
se révèlent bien
plus graves de jour en jour.
Au-delà
de toutes ces images,
il y a cet élan de solidarité,
une entraide naturelle
envers les plus faibles.
De nombreux habitants
se changent
en sauveteurs aux côtés
des centaines
de policiers, gendarmes,
sapeurs-pompiers,
agents de sécurité
civile, associations
et organismes de secours.
Leur engagement
est exceptionnel:
2300 interventions,
1400 personnes évacuées,
des centaines
de communes sécurisées.
Tout simplement, merci à eux.
Dès les premières heures,
les maires
et leurs équipes
ont répondu présent.
Chaque jour et chaque nuit,
ils se démènent
et portent haut
les valeurs
de notre République.
A court terme, quid
de la reconstruction
et du relogement des sinistrés?
A long terme,
nous devons nous engager
sur la prévention
de la montée des eaux.
Les habitants nous le demandent.
Le Pas-de-Calais a besoin de vous.
Pouvez-vous nous redonner
de l'espoir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Dominique Faure,
ministre en charge
des Collectivités territoriales
et de la Ruralité.
- Dominique Faure:
Madame la députée,
nous nous associons
à vos remerciements
pour la mobilisation
des policiers,
des gendarmes, des agents
de sécurité civile,
des associations
et organismes de secours
qui ont fait un travail
extraordinaire
en cette période de crise.
Nous sommes tous
solidaires des milliers
de personnes sinistrées.
Le Pas-de-Calais
a effectivement connu
un épisode pluvieux intense
ces derniers jours
qui faisait suite à des cumuls
déjà exceptionnels intervenant
dans un contexte hydrologique
extrêmement préoccupant.
Sur les 247 communes
touchées, la priorité
est à la réponse
d'urgence et au retour
à la normale.
550 foyers restent
privés d'électricité.
Celle-ci ne pourra
être rétablie
par les services
d'Enedis que lorsque
le niveau de l'eau
permettra de mettre hors
de l'eau les postes électriques.
150 km de routes
restent encore coupées.
Les établissements
scolaires demeurent
fermés jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Vous évoquez la question
du relogement
des sinistrés.
La prise en charge
s'est concentrée
sur les personnes vulnérables.
Depuis le 6 novembre,
54 personnes
ont été prises en charge
dans un hébergement dédié.
En ce qui concerne
la reconstruction suite
aux dégâts causés
par les inondations,
les personnes
physiques résidant
dans l'une des 244
communes ayant
fait l'objet d'une
reconnaissance
par l'Etat de catastrophe
naturelle pourront faire l'objet
d'une indemnisation
des dommages causés
aux biens,
ce qui devrait permettre
la reconstruction.
Une cellule dédiée
aux entreprises
et aux exploitants agricoles
a également été mise
en place par la préfecture.
La fréquence et l'intensité
de ces phénomènes climatiques
ayant vocation
à s'accélérer
dans le cadre
du réchauffement climatique,
nous devons adapter
nos territoires
pour y faire face,
et c'est le sens
du nouveau plan
national d'adaptation
de la France
au changement climatique
qui est porté
par Christophe Béchu
et qui sera lancé
en début d'année 2024.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Francesca Pasquini.
- Francesca Pasquini:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre
des Affaires étrangères.
Je pense
que nous sommes d'accord:
un enfant,
où qu'il se trouve,
mérite notre protection.
La France s'est
engagée à le faire
en ratifiant la Convention
internationale
des droits de l'enfant
qui a une valeur juridique
contraignante, obligatoire
et non négociable.
Que l'enfant se trouve
à quelques mètres
de nous ou à Gaza,
nous nous devons d'agir.
Trop peu de voix
s'élèvent pour décrire
la tragédie des enfants de Gaza.
La moitié des Gazaouis
sont des enfants.
Depuis le 8 octobre,
4500 enfants
sont morts.
En moyenne, 120 par jour.
8500 sont portés disparus.
Certains des blessés
ont été amputés
sans anesthésie générale.
L'Unicef est clair:
Gaza est devenu
un cimetière pour enfants.
La vie d'un million
d'entre eux ne tient
plus qu'à un fil.
Le temps presse
pour leur venir en aide.
Pour ceux qui sont encore
en vie,
la peur, la faim
et la soif les tenaillent.
Le traitement des eaux
usées est coupé,
avec les conséquences
sanitaires
que vous imaginez.
Cela s'ajoute
aux traumatismes
qui les accompagneront
toute leur vie.
Les actes du gouvernement
israélien
sont en contradiction
avec la Convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant
que l'Etat d'Israël
a pourtant ratifié.
La France ne doit pas rester
passive face
à ces crimes de guerre
dont des milliers d'enfants
sont victimes.
Avec l'appui
de plusieurs collègues,
nous avons demandé
à la délégation
aux droits
des enfants de lancer
une mission sur le sort
des enfants Gazaouis.
Pouvez-vous
nous indiquer
quelles sont les mesures
concrètes prises
par le gouvernement
pour porter secours
et assistance à ces enfants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
vous avez raison
de soulever l'urgence
humanitaire,
car les besoins
sont criants à Gaza.
L'aide doit pouvoir passer
en plus grand nombre
au point de passage de Rafah.
La communauté internationale
s'est mobilisée.
La France y a apporté
déjà 80 huit tonnes
de fret livrées sur place.
Cette aide doit passer.
Il faut faire davantage.
C'est pour cette raison
que la France
a organisé jeudi
dernier la conférence
que j'évoquais avec les principaux
partenaires internationaux,
les Nations Unies,
les organisations spécialisées.
Outre
les contributions,
dont celle de la France,
100 millions d'euros,
cette conférence
a permis d'acter
un consensus en faveur d'une
trêve immédiate,
durable et soutenue
qui puisse garantir
que l'aide parvienne
aux populations.
C'est un pas concret.
Nous poursuivrons nos efforts
pour matérialiser
cela sur le terrain au plus vite.
Bien sûr,
chaque jour compte,
chaque vie compte,
qu'il s'agisse
de la vie d'un enfant
ou d'un adulte.
Je souhaite répéter
que la lutte
contre le terrorisme doit
se faire conformément
au droit international.
C'est un impératif
légal, morale,
et c'est la force
des démocraties
que de mener la lutte
contre le terrorisme
dans le respect
du droit international.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la ministre.
La parole est à madame
Elsa Faucillon.
- Elsa Faucillon:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les ministres,
à Gaza, ceux qui survivent
aux bombes risquent
de mourir de faim,
de soif ou faute
de soins.
11.240 Palestiniens
ont été tués
par les bombardements
israéliens
depuis les attaques
terroristes du Hamas.
Gaza est devenu
un cimetière pour enfants.
4630 sont déjà morts.
Alors que des hôpitaux bénéficient
d'une protection particulière
en vertu du droit
international humanitaire,
des témoignages
et des images d'horreur
nous proviennent
de l'hôpital Al-Shifa.
A Gaza, aujourd'hui,
plus de 22
des 35 hôpitaux
sont en arrêt total
ou partiel avec la pénurie
de carburant.
Sans électricité,
eau ni nourriture,
c'est le chaos qui règne.
Selon l'agence
onusienne, le nombre
de déplacés s'élève
à 1,6 million
de personnes
sur les 2,4 millions
de Gazaouis.
En Cisjordanie,
nous assistons
à des centaines
d'attaques par des colons
et des expulsions de communauté.
194 Palestiniens ont été
tués par l'armée
et par des milices de colons.
Des ministres israéliens
ont été jusqu'à
se mettre en scène
en train de distribuer
des armes à des colons.
C'est la traduction du projet
de Benyamin Netanyahou,
le même qu'avant
les attaques du Hamas.
C'est la volonté d'une
occupation complète
de la Palestine.
A Gaza, l'escalade
vengeresse se transforme
en nettoyage ethnique.
Pourtant, depuis 1948,
ce sont 104 résolutions
de l'ONU sur la situation
en Palestine
qui sont restées lettres mortes.
Pendant cette période,
la communauté internationale
est restée silencieuse
et donc impuissante.
Emmanuel Macron
a affirmé
il y a quelques jours
qu'il fallait aller
vers un cessez-le-feu,
enfin,
mais cela semble
en permanence contredit
par d'autres phrases.
La paix vous paraît
peut-être impensable.
Nous croyons qu'elle est possible.
Elle nécessite des actes forts.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Colonna,
ministre des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Faucillon,
à Gaza, quelle est l'urgence?
Bien sûr, la première urgence
est humanitaire.
Il faut que l'aide stockée du côté
égyptien puisse passer
à la population
civile de Gaza
pour répondre
aux besoins criants
des populations.
L'urgence,
c'est de ne pas laisser
une catastrophe
humanitaire s'aggraver,
c'est d'apporter de l'aide
de façon urgente
et durable.
Cela impose une pause
dans les opérations militaires
pour que les soignants
puissent entrer,
pour que l'aide puisse
être distribuée,
pour que les blessés
les plus graves puissent
être évacués.
A partir de là,
il faut être pragmatique.
Que peut-on obtenir aujourd'hui?
Une trêve humanitaire
et immédiate qui,
ensuite, pourra amener
à un cessez-le-feu.
C'est le consensus
international
que la France
a contribué à forger
lors de la conférence
humanitaire jeudi dernier.
Il faut une pause
le plus rapidement possible
et sans attendre.
Il faut aussi oeuvrer
à un cessez-le-feu
et à la restauration d'une
perspective politique,
mais sans permettre
au Hamas de reconstituer
ses capacités et de mener
ses actions terroristes,
car nul ne doit oublier
quel est l'objectif
de cette organisation
terroriste,
et surtout ne pas
l'oublier
après ce qu'il s'est
passé le 7 octobre.
Ne l'oublions pas.
Rien ne justifie
jamais le terrorisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Matthieu Marchio.
- Matthieu Marchio:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
du Plein emploi et du Travail.
plus de 3 millions
de Français
sont sans emploi.
Alors que tant de
nos compatriotes
sont au chômage
partout en France,
dans les outre-mer
comme dans le nord,
votre seule réponse
est de régulariser
des clandestins,
une régularisation
qui va créer
un nouvel appel d'air
à toujours plus d'immigration.
Pour tous
les Français vivant
dans la précarité
et au chômage,
vous êtes hors-sol,
déconnecté
de la réalité
de ceux qui souffrent.
Votre projet
est un non-sens économique.
Vous tirez à la baisse
les salaires
de l'ensemble
des travailleurs,
créant ainsi une situation
de concurrence déloyale,
notamment dans les emplois
difficiles
et souvent mal payés.
C'est en augmentant de 10%
les bas salaires
comme le propose Marine Le Pen,
en revalorisant
le travail manuel
qui ne saurait
être exercé
que par des clandestins
exploités honteusement,
en améliorant
les conditions de travail
dans le secteur
de la logistique,
en réduisant le coût
du carburant...
Vous qui avez été socialiste
puis macroniste,
vous vous êtes associé
à une politique économique
et pro-immigration
qui a fait
tant de mal aux Français.
Votre projet
incarne le pire,
entre l'ouverture
de la gauche à l'immigration
et l'ouverture
à l'ultralibéralisme
de la droite.
Cette alliance
néfaste qui a mis
le bassin minier
du Nord,
dont je suis élu, à terre.
Quel est l'intérêt
de vouloir régulariser
les clandestins
dans un pays qui compte
plus de 3 millions de chômeurs?
- Elisabeth Borne:
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
vous prenez prétexte d'une
disposition de loi
en cours d'examen
sur l'immigration
et l'intégration
pour aborder
la question du chômage.
Je vous rappelle
que la disposition
que nous avions envisagée
avec Gérald Darmanin
et la disposition
votée par le Sénat
avec des critères durcis
n'a qu'un objectif:
permettre
de régulariser
non pas de nouveaux
immigrés,
non pas des personnes
qui travaillent
de manière illégale,
mais d'apporter
une possibilité
de régularisation
à des hommes
et des femmes
qui sont présents
sur notre territoire,
qui travaillent
depuis longtemps
et qui travaillent légalement.
Ne vous en déplaise,
dans notre pays,
on peut avoir un contrat
de travail
sans avoir de titre de séjour.
Bien souvent,
ce sont des personnes
qui ont signé
un contrat de travail
quand ils avaient un titre
de séjour.
A travers
cette question,
et je ne préjuge pas
du débat
de ces prochains
jours, vous dites
que la priorité
est de faire baisser
le chômage.
Nous partageons cette priorité.
Depuis 6 ans,
l'économie française,
grâce à notre politique,
a créé 2 millions d'emplois.
L'économie française a créé
140.000 emplois nets
au cours de la dernière année.
Vous ne partagez pas
cette priorité.
Quand on vote une réforme
de l'assurance-chômage
pour que les règles soient
plus incitatives,
vous n'êtes pas là
et vous votez contre.
Quand on débat
pour faire en sorte
que les allocataires du RSA
puissent participer
à 15 heures d'activités
d'insertion,
vous votez contre.
Quand on veut faciliter
l'accès à l'emploi
des personnes
en situation de handicap,
vous votez contre.
Quand on vote
des mesures pour faire
en sorte que le plan
d'investissement
dans les compétences
qui a permis
de multiplier par 2,5 le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi formés,
qui est l'objectif
de la loi plein emploi,
vous votez contre.
Monsieur le député,
le Front National dénonce
un système,
mais ne fait rien
ni pour l'emploi,
ni pour sortir
celles
et ceux qui sont au chômage.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Blandine Brocard.
- Blandine Brocard:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
des Solidarités et des Familles.
Madame la ministre,
plus de 3 millions,
c'est le nombre d'enfants,
de femmes, d'hommes qui,
aujourd'hui,
en France,
ne mangent pas à leur faim,
souffrant
de précarité
alimentaire,
comme il est de coutume
de dire
par fausse politesse.
Les différentes crises
qui se succèdent
depuis 4 ans
dans notre pays
et ont accentué
les difficultés
des Français les plus démunis.
La générosité
de nos concitoyens,
l'engagement
des associations
et de leurs bénévoles,
l'action résolue
de l'Etat
et des collectivités
apportent des réponses
à la lutte
contre ce fléau.
L'Union Européenne
propose des programmes
de lutte contre la précarité
alimentaire, ainsi,
le fonds européen d'aide
aux plus démunis
a été doté de 3,3
milliards d'euros
pour sa programmation
2014-2020,
dont 443 millions
d'euros ont été alloués
à la France.
Ce fonds permet
à l'Etat d'acheter
des denrées
alimentaires
pour les plus pauvres
et de les distribuer
à quatre associations
caritatives:
les Restos du Coeur,
le Secours populaire,
la Croix-Rouge
et la Fédération française
des banques alimentaires.
J'ai été alerté
par le Secours populaire
sur le fait qu'une
partie de ce fonds
n'aurait pas été
totalement engagée
alors même que la date
limite est fixée
au 31 décembre
de cette année,
soit dans quelques semaines.
Pouvez-vous m'assurer
que la totalité
de ce fonds sera engagé
dans les délais?
D'autre part,
pour la période 2022-2027,
l'Union Européenne a fléché 647
millions d'euros
pour le nouveau programme
de soutien européen
à l'aide alimentaire au sein
du fonds social européen,
avec un financement de 90%
des dépenses effectuées.
Pouvez-vous nous donner
des informations
sur le pilotage
de ce fonds
et sur les actions
de l'Etat pour lutter
contre la faim?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Je ne suis pas ministre
des Solidarités,
mais Aurore Bergé
est en déplacement
avec le président
de la République.
Merci d'avoir souligné
le soutien
de l'Europe.
Il faut que l'on insiste
à chaque fois
sur le fait
que l'Europe intervient
dans le quotidien des Français.
C'est l'Europe
qui intervient en soutien
de l'aide alimentaire.
Ca existe depuis 1987.
Pour 2014-2021,
le soutien est passé
par deux programmes:
le fonds européen
aux plus démunis
et un plan
qui est mis en place
pour faire face
à la crise sanitaire.
Ces crédits ont permis aux grandes
associations d'aide alimentaire,
les Restos du Coeur,
les banques alimentaires,
le Secours populaire
et la Croix-Rouge,
qui représentent 90%
des distributions,
de bénéficier de 90.000 tonnes
de produits annuelles
au bénéfice des bénéficiaires.
Des marchés existent
pour une trentaine
de produits définis.
Même si l'Union
Européenne cofinance
ces programmes,
les crédits sont d'abord avancés
contrôle pour le mieux.
Après les contrôles,
une partie
des dépenses effectuées
ont été soumises
à d'autres contrôles.
La France a bien utilisé
tous les leviers
à sa disposition
pour maximiser l'utilisation
des fonds européens en faveur
de l'aide alimentaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Boris Vallaud.
- Boris Vallaud:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
la semaine dernière,
l'Assemblée nationale
votait à l'unanimité
à l'initiative
du groupe socialiste
et avec l'avis
favorable du ministre
en charge du budget une aide
exceptionnelle destinée
aux familles
monoparentales vivant
sous le seuil
de pauvreté, entre 115
et 200 euros pour aider
600.000 familles
à terminer une année
difficile,
après une inflation
alimentaire
parmi les plus fortes jamais vues.
Des mamans seules
pour lesquelles
tout est difficile.
Nous observons
dans nos circonscriptions
ce problème.
Nous avons fait
de ce sujet un groupe
de travail transpartisan.
Une mesure urgente est nécessaire.
Le Secours Catholique,
après les Restos
du Coeur, a lancé un cri d'alarme.
Nous devons
nous en inquiéter
et nous mobiliser.
Il y a quelques jours,
alors que beaucoup
de familles partageaient
un soulagement
bien relatif,
le ministre de l'Economie
et le ministre
des Budgets, alors même
que cette loi
n'est pas votée,
a jugé cette prime
de Noël:
"C'est de l'argent
dépensé pour rien."
Madame la Première
ministre, pouvez-vous
nous dire si venir en aide
à des mamans seules
et si venir en aide
à des enfants pauvres
c'est d'argent
dépensé pour rien
pour des familles
qui sans cela ne seraient rien?
Que doit-on comprendre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le président Boris
Vallaud, je crois
que nous sommes sur un sujet
trop sérieux
pour se prêter
à des polémiques
comme vous êtes
en train de le faire.
Je peux vous assurer
que je suis parfaitement
consciente
que la forte inflation
que l'on connaît
depuis ces derniers mois pèse
sur le quotidien
de nos concitoyens.
C'est l'inflation liée
à la reprise post-Covid
et à la guerre en Ukraine.
Je peux
vous assurer aussi
que depuis le premier
jour, la majorité,
mon gouvernement
est mobilisé pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des Français.
Nous avons protégé
le pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens
plus qu'aucun autre pays
en Europe.
C'est le sens des dispositifs
exceptionnels
sur l'énergie,
les boucliers tarifaires.
Je rappelle que c'est 46
milliards d'euros
pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
C'est le sens de l'indemnité
carburant-travailleur
que nous allons
reconduire en 2024
et qui bénéficiera
désormais à 60%
de nos concitoyens
pour mieux protéger
les classes moyennes.
C'est le sens
encore des mesures prises
pour lutter contre l'inflation
alimentaire.
Je pense aussi au panier
anti-inflation
qui concerne
plus de 5000 produits.
Vous aurez l'occasion
de voter le projet
de loi qui permet d'accélérer
les négociations commerciales
pour accélérer la baisse
de l'inflation alimentaire.
Nous sommes attentifs
à cela,
et je vous remercie
de me donner l'occasion
de le dire:
le pouvoir d'achat
des plus modestes,
la revalorisation
des prestations
sociales, l'indexation
des pensions,
l'indexation du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu.
C'est 25 milliards
d'euros dans le projet
de loi de finances
de la Sécurité sociale.
Je parlerai aussi
de l'augmentation
des plus petites retraites.
Avec la réforme
des retraites,
il y aura une revalorisation
des pensions minimales,
600 euros par an
pour 1,7 million
de nos concitoyens.
Je vous le confirme:
nous avons accepté
un amendement
de votre groupe qui porte
une préoccupation
largement partagée
sur les bancs de la majorité
pour mieux accompagner
les familles isolées.
C'est un combat que mène
la majorité avec,
par exemple,
le versement automatique
des pensions
pour les familles
et les mères célibataires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Julie Delpech.
- Julie Delpech:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'Etat chargée
de l'Enfance.
Madame la ministre,
ce samedi aura lieu
la huitième
journée européenne
pour la protection
des enfants
contre l'exploitation
et les abus sexuels.
Près de 13% des femmes et 5%
des hommes disent
avoir été victimes
d'abus sexuels
durant leur enfance.
Ces chiffres sont effroyables.
Ils cachent
une réalité souvent
très difficile
à évoquer pour nombre
de nos concitoyens.
Un enfant
victime d'abus,
c'est une vie entière affectée.
Leur existence
ne ressemble
à aucune autre.
Nous leur devons
notre dévouement
pour que plus personne
ne puisse subir
de telles atrocités.
S'il nous reste bien
évidemment du chemin
à parcourir afin
de libérer la parole,
je souhaite
tout d'abord saluer ici
notre prise
de conscience collective
autour de ces sujets
qui se voient renforcés
par la campagne lancée
contre l'inceste.
Je souhaite saluer
les progrès introduits
par le gouvernement
et la majorité,
tout particulièrement
depuis 2021,
ainsi que le travail
transpartisan
qui a conduit à l'adoption
en deuxième lecture
d'un texte essentiel, hier soir.
Avec la réforme
de la gouvernance
de la protection de l'enfance,
le contrôle systématique
des antécédents judiciaires
des encadrants,
la désignation
des référents
contre les violences
dans les établissements sociaux
et médico-sociaux,
la mise en place
d'un référentiel
unique partagé
ou encore une meilleure
prise en charge
des cas de prostitution
sur mineurs,
nous avons mis en place
des outils importants
pour la protection de nos enfants.
Madame la ministre,
je sais et salue
votre engagement
sur ces sujets
ainsi que celui du gouvernement.
Je souhaiterais
savoir
quelles sont les pistes
envisagées afin
de poursuivre
cette lutte, notamment
contre l'inceste
et les abus sexuels
sur les mineurs.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole est à madame
Charlotte Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Madame la députée
Delpech, merci
de rappeler une nouvelle fois
ces chiffres intolérables
que nous devons
marteler
tant qu'ils ne bougeront pas.
Un enfant est victime
dans ce pays
toutes les 3 minutes
de violences sexuelles.
Merci aussi
de rappeler la réalité
de vie brisée d'enfants,
puis d'adultes,
brisés par ces violences
contre lesquelles
nous devons lutter.
Le président
de la République
en a fait une priorité
de ce quinquennat.
C'est pour cela que la Première
ministre
en a fait la priorité du comité
interministériel
de l'Enfance.
Nous avons fait déjà
un certain nombre
de choses dans le précédent
quinquennat
et encore dans ce quinquennat.
Je pourrais rappeler
la généralisation
et le travail
de la commission indépendante
sur l'inceste.
Beaucoup de choses ont été faites.
Nous pouvons saluer
cette adoption hier
à l'unanimité
de la proposition de loi
en deuxième lecture.
C'est un formidable outil
à la disposition
de la protection des enfants.
Il nous faut continuer à agir.
Je le crains, le plan qui sera
présenté lundi prochain
par la Première
ministre
ne sera pas le dernier.
Il nous faut agir
contre des pratiques
et des cultures
plus que millénaires.
Nous proposerons
un certain nombre
de propositions
nouvelles en nous axant
sur la prévention, le repérage,
l'accompagnement
des victimes
et la répression des auteurs
de ces violences.
Il nous faut
évidemment continuer
à nous battre, maintenir
le formidable élan lancé
par la commission
indépendante sur l'inceste,
et bien évidemment,
je compte sur vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Maxime Laisney.
- Maxime Laisney:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre
de la Transition énergétique,
madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
Au printemps dernier,
vous avez cherché
à imposer la dissolution
de l'institut
de radioprotection
et de sûreté nucléaire.
Nous vous avons battu.
Après un rapport
prétexte, vous revenez
avec un nouveau projet
de loi pour mettre fin
à la séparation
de l'expertise
et de la décision
en deux entités distinctes.
L'incompréhension reste
totale et constitue
le premier motif
de d'opposition
des salariés,
où les démissions
ont progressé de 50%.
Le président de cet
institut cherche
à répondre aux exigences
de nouveaux opérateurs,
des start-up
qui devraient gérer
les petits réacteurs nucléaires.
Vous nous avez donc menti.
Le Conseil constitutionnel
a confirmé
à deux reprises
qu'EDF dispose
d'un monopole de production
d'électricité nucléaire
en France.
Vous avez pourtant
confié
cela à des entreprises privées
qui auront passé
des contrats
avec de gros clients
pour leur livret
d'électricité à prix fixe
durant de nombreuses années.
Vous nous préparez
les ingrédients
de la catastrophe
de Fukushima
pour laquelle le parlement
japonais estime
que la responsabilité
de l'accident réside
principalement en la négligence
de l'opérateur,
et rend la complaisance
de l'organe
de réglementation à cet égard.
Il pourrait
y avoir une irradiation
bien réelle
et des territoires sacrifiés.
Madame la ministre
de la "trahison énergétique",
il est temps de dire la vérité.
Pourquoi brader
la sûreté nucléaire
alors que la filière
est déjà confrontée
à tant d'impasses?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député,
vous n'aimez pas le nucléaire.
Vous n'aimez pas EDF.
Vous n'aimez
surtout pas la réalité
des faits.
La privatisation
du nucléaire est donc
votre nouvelle
invention pour jeter
le discrédit
sur une filière qui réunit
des dizaines
de milliers d'hommes
et de femmes
qui sont à notre service
et qui, chaque matin,
garantissent
la livraison d'une
électricité bas-carbone,
compétitive
et moins chère
que dans le reste de l'Europe.
Moi, je veux
leur rendre hommage
à ces 220.000 personnes
qui,
tous les matins,
sont sur notre territoire
pour produire
et pour faire en sorte
que nous vivions mieux.
Monsieur le député,
attaquer le nucléaire
qui permet aux industriels
de produire,
aux Français
de se déplacer
et de se chauffer,
c'est attaquer l'excellence
de la France.
A croire
que vous n'aimez pas la France.
A chaque fois que vous attaquez
le nucléaire,
c'est aussi le travail
de ces instituts
que vous critiquez.
Qui a organisé la montée
au capital d'EDF?
Ce gouvernement.
Qui a pris
la décision d'étendre
les tarifs
réglementés
pour les très petites entreprises?
Ce gouvernement.
Alors, assez de vos mensonges!
Pendant que vous racontez
des bobards,
nous agissons concrètement
pour relancer
le nucléaire,
car le succès
de cette relance,
et ce n'est pas moi
qui le dis
mais l'Office public
des choix scientifiques
et technologiques
du Parlement,
dans son rapport de juillet,
ça passe par cette nouvelle
autorité
qui va permettre non
seulement d'améliorer
les procédures
pour répondre aux défis
de la relance,
de garantir l'indépendance
de l'autorité vis-à-vis
des exploitants nucléaires
et du gouvernement,
de renforcer
la transparence
vis-à-vis du public
et de rendre attractifs
ces métiers.
- Maxime Laisney:
La seule bonne nouvelle
dans tout ça,
c'est qu'à force
de tout casser,
vous allez empêcher
la relance du nucléaire
dans le pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Pierre-Henri Dumont.
- Pierre-Henri Dumont:
Madame la Première ministre,
depuis plusieurs
jours, les habitants
de mon département
sont frappés
par des inondations
consécutives
à des précipitations inédites.
Au nom des Républicains,
je tiens
à leur témoigner
notre soutien absolu.
Nous remercions
les forces de secours
et les citoyens
qui luttent au quotidien
pour mettre en sécurité
les personnes,
les animaux et les biens.
Aujourd'hui,
alors que nous vivons
sous la menace de nouvelles
précipitations,
et donc de nouvelles
crues, l'heure
est à l'entraide.
Demain, nous devrons
panser nos plaies.
La mesure annoncée
par le président
de la République ce matin
est un premier pas,
mais elle semble
déjà insuffisante
et elle ne sera
efficace
que si les assurances
débloquent rapidement
les fonds.
Depuis plusieurs années,
nous vous alertons
sur la situation
catastrophique
d'un système essentiel
à l'évacuation
des eaux, un système
qui souffre
d'un sous-investissement
chronique
depuis le désengagement de l'Etat.
En réponse à nos alertes,
nous n'avons obtenu
de la part du gouvernement
que du mépris.
C'est ce mépris
que nous payons aujourd'hui.
Les concitoyens sont exaspérés.
Les bouleversements
climatiques,
la brutalité
des précipitations,
la montée des océans
mettent à mal
notre système
d'évacuation des eaux
vers la mer.
Sans investissements massifs,
nous subirons demain
ou après-demain
de nouvelles inondations.
Nous demandons la création
d'un fonds exceptionnel afin
de construire
de nouveaux ouvrages
de retenue,
mais aussi pour curer
les canaux et consolider
les berges.
Allez-vous répondre
au cri de désespoir
des habitants et des élus
de mon département?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Pierre-Henri Dumont,
je suis très surprise
par vos propos d'ignorance,
de mépris que vous percevez.
Je voudrais
tout d'abord souligner
le soutien du gouvernement,
mais aussi
de vous tous,
j'en suis certaine,
pour les sinistrés
de la succession d'intempéries
qui touchent le Pas-de-Calais.
Il fallait écouter
précisément les réponses
que j'ai données précédemment.
Les services d'Etat
ont essayé de limiter
le nombre de blessés
et les conséquences humaines
de cette catastrophe.
Ce n'est pas
moins de 61.000 personnes
qui ont été évacuées.
Je veux souligner
la mobilisation remarquable
des sapeurs-pompiers
qui ont procédé
à ces opérations.
Je vais
vous répondre,
si vous avez un brin de patience.
935 sapeurs-pompiers
et militaires
de la sécurité civile
sont mobilisés,
dont 410
qui sont en provenance
de toute la France,
au service
de nos sinistrés.
De très importants
moyens humains
et de pompage ont été
déployés afin
de vider les zones
inondées et de protéger
les digues.
Ces actions sont essentielles
pour éviter
une dégradation
de la situation,
mais aussi
pour permettre un retour
le plus rapidement possible
à une vie normale,
que ce soit pour
les particuliers
ou pour les entreprises.
A ce jour, il est un peu
tôt pour dégager
un chiffrage global
de la catastrophe.
Il est nécessaire
d'attendre le retrait
des eaux.
Le gouvernement
se tient aux côtés
des sinistrés,
des élus locaux
et du tissu économique.
Je vais vous répondre.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer
et le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion
des territoires
étaient sur place
mercredi dernier
pour simplement prouver
notre solidarité,
prendre la mesure
et prendre les décisions.
Le président de la République
est également
sur place en ce moment.
Le dispositif
de catastrophe naturelle
est passé en procédure
accélérée
en ce début d'après-midi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame...
Excusez-moi,
vous avez trois secondes.
- Pierre-Henri Dumont:
Vous prouvez
que vous n'y connaissez rien.
Votre réponse
est en dessous de tout.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Maud Petit.
- Maud Petit:
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education
nationale,
depuis le 29 septembre,
plusieurs établissements scolaires
sont touchés
par d'incessantes alertes
à la bombe qui perturbent
leur fonctionnement,
provoquant évacuations
et fermetures.
Dans le Val-de-Marne,
un lycée
de ma circonscription détient
le nombre record d'alertes
en Ile-de-France.
Sur 40 alertes
dans la région,
ce lycée on comptabilise
la moitié.
Au-delà de la question
de sécurité
qui mobilise
nos forces de l'ordre,
je vous interpelle
sur la continuité pédagogique mise
à mal depuis deux mois
par des évacuations parfois
quotidiennes
et une désorganisation
des cours en conséquence.
Avec plus de la moitié
des heures annulées,
le désespoir des élèves
est palpable.
Les parents s'inquiètent
à la perspective
des examens,
et plusieurs questions
se posent.
Comment permettre
le rattrapage
des heures de cours?
80 heures ont été
perdues dans ce lycée.
Comment enseigner
Parcoursup en janvier
quand on sait
que la plate-forme intègre
des absences involontaires?
Un bac 100% contrôle
continu peut-il
être envisagé
pour ces établissements?
Une solution
alternative a été mise
en place
ponctuellement,
mais elle fait
écho chez certains
à l'époque du confinement.
Les cours virtuels
ont subi une intrusion
de personnes mal intentionnées,
expulsant même
les professeurs
de leur classe virtuelle.
Je ne doute pas que des solutions
soient recherchées activement,
mais l'absence de communication
attise l'incompréhension
et le sentiment d'abandon.
Le temps passe
et la colère des parents
et des professeurs
se fait plus forte
de jour en jour.
Quelles réponses concrètes
pouvez-vous apporter
à ces élèves,
à ces enseignants
et à ces professeurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Madame la députée Maud Petit,
merci beaucoup
pour cette question.
Je me permets
de répondre en place
et lieu de Gabriel Attal,
qui est retenu cet après-midi
à Marseille.
Vous avez raison,
depuis le mois
de septembre, ce sont 996
fausses alertes
à la bombe
que nous recensons
dans notre pays.
Sur ces 996 alertes
à la bombe,
ce sont 788
dans le seul endroit
de nos établissements scolaires.
Face à cela,
et je rejoins vos propos,
nous devons en premier
lieu saluer
la mobilisation de tous,
en premier lieu l'équipe
éducative,
les enseignants
ainsi que nos forces
de l'ordre,
les gendarmes,
les policiers
et nos services
de secours
qui sont sur le qui-vive
pour assurer
la sécurité de l'entièreté
des personnels
au sein des établissements
scolaires
comme de nos enfants.
Je tiens également
à rappeler
quelque chose d'utile.
Les fausses alertes à la bombe
mobilisent inutilement
nos forces de sécurité.
Elles permettent aussi de retarder
malheureusement l'intervention
de nos forces de sécurité
et de secours auprès
de celles
et ceux qui en ont réellement
besoin.
Elles participent à encourir
à 30.000 euros d'amende
et deux ans d'emprisonnement.
Depuis le mois de septembre,
54 personnes
ont été interpellées,
dont 30
sur le dernier mois.
Je vois votre impatience,
je vais répondre
sur la continuité
pédagogique,
mais permettez-moi
de rappeler ces sujets
qui sont importants.
Peut-être qu'ils auront
une résonance auprès
de celles
et ceux qui en sont coupables
aujourd'hui
pour qu'ils comprennent
qu'ils ne seront pas gardés
dans l'impunité.
Sur la continuité
pédagogique,
nous devons
évidemment l'assurer,
comme la prudence
est d'assurer la sécurité
de nos établissements
scolaires face
à ces fausses alertes.
Nous devons
avoir des dispositifs
à l'endroit des jeunes,
des dispositifs particuliers
avec des extensions
d'horaires d'ouverture,
mais aussi des stages
de réussite
et des cours de rattrapage.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Christine Engrand
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Christine Engrand:
247 communes inondées,
1391 évacuations,
2426 mobilisations
de pompiers,
dont nous saluons l'action:
voilà le bilan
provisoire à ce jour
des tempêtes
Ciaran et Domingos
et des précipitations
consécutives
qui se sont abattues
sur le Pas-de-Calais
et une partie du Nord.
Aujourd'hui,
les pompes manquent
pour pallier
la hausse du niveau
de la mer.
Il a fallu déménager
jeudi soir
des pompes.
Les bassins sont mal entretenus.
Des vannes sont cassées
ou mal remontées.
Les cantonniers communaux
ont disparu faute
de moyens.
Les fossés,
les rivières
ne sont plus curés.
Par endroits,
pour ne pas importuner
quelques grenouilles
ou quelques anguilles,
on préfère laisser
les personnes âgées
les pieds dans l'eau.
Le caractère exceptionnel
de ces phénomènes climatiques
appelle à la mise en oeuvre
d'un cadre d'exception efficace
pour tout reconstruire
rapidement
une fois cette catastrophe
terminée.
Cela implique des procédures
de déclaration
de sinistre simplifiées,
une franchise allégée,
un gel du montant
des cotisations,
une suspension
des prélèvements fiscaux
et sociaux,
un engagement de l'Etat
à compenser
l'ensemble des pertes
qui ne pourraient pas
être prises
en charge par les assurances.
Je pense aussi
aux biens immobiliers
et à toutes ces petites
entreprises
et petites exploitations
agricoles,
ces maraîchers
pour qui s'assurer coûte
trop cher
et que ce gouvernement refuse
de protéger
par la solidarité nationale
de la même manière que les autres.
En parallèle, il faudra adapter
le système actuel
aux enjeux climatiques
avec des investissements pérennes
et efficaces.
Il faudra comprendre
que le caractère exceptionnel
de ces intempéries
ne saurait occulter
les failles de la gouvernance.
Le manque de moyens
a été révélé
au grand jour.
Il nous faut des solutions
à court terme
et à long terme.
Qu'envisagez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Dominique Faure,
ministre en charge
des Collectivités territoriales
et de la Ruralité.
- Dominique Faure: Merci.
Madame la députée,
merci de saluer
le travail
de nos forces civiles
et militaires.
Merci de saluer le travail
de nos élus locaux.
On partage le diagnostic.
Vous l'avez dit,
ce sont 244 communes
qui ont fait l'objet
d'une reconnaissance
de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle.
C'était aujourd'hui.
Les arrêtés seront prêts demain.
Je l'ai déjà dit précédemment.
C'est aussi 50
millions d'euros
que le président
de la République
a annoncés.
Ce sera un investissement
exceptionnel
pour les communes.
Certains peuvent
penser
que ce ne sera pas
suffisant,
mais on est en train de travailler
d'abord
à l'urgence, ensuite
à porter un diagnostic,
à mesurer les besoins
en travaux,
et donc, ces 50
millions d'euros
ont été décidés
dans l'urgence maintenant
et seront dans la dotation
de solidarité
des communes.
Cette dotation permet
en plus aux collectivités touchées
par un événement
climatique ou géologique
de bénéficier d'une subvention
de 150.000 euros
à 6 millions d'euros.
Elle vise la reconstruction,
la remise
en état des infrastructures
routières,
des ouvrages d'art,
des biens annexes
à la voirie, des réseaux
de distribution
et d'assainissement d'eau.
Nous nous tenons
donc dans l'urgence
aux côtés de chacun
et chacune
qui est touché
par cette catastrophe,
et nous déployons tous
les moyens nécessaires
pour les accompagner
dès aujourd'hui
au quotidien.
Sur le moyen terme
que vous appelez
de vos voeux, bien sûr
que nous ferons
un retour d'expérience
pour tirer
tous les enseignements
de ce sinistre
pour être toujours
aux côtés
de nos concitoyens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Avant de donner la parole
au prochain orateur,
je rappelle qu'à compter
de la semaine prochaine,
nous reviendrons au rythme
de deux séances hebdomadaires
de questions au gouvernement.
La séance du mardi
comprendra 18 questions
et s'achèvera donc vers 16h15.
Une seconde séance
de 45 minutes
vous permettra d'interroger
le gouvernement
à l'issue du Conseil
des ministres,
le mercredi, à 14h.
C'est une expérimentation
qui durera 10 semaines
et que nous pourrons
évaluer tous ensemble.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Marc Tellier.
- Jean-Michel Tellier:
Les tempêtes successives
ont d'abord frappé durement
le Pas-de-Calais.
Les crues exceptionnelles
ont causé
des dégâts sans précédent.
Ces déchaînements ont ravagé
des zones agricoles,
des entreprises,
mais ont également détruit
nos infrastructures,
écoles, routes
et surtout endommagé
de nombreuses habitations.
Derrière cette catastrophe,
c'est d'abord
des familles qui sont dévastées
et probablement beaucoup
de rêves
qui sont brisés
qu'il nous appartient
de reconstruire.
Permettez-moi
de saluer
avec la plus grande
gratitude
ceux qui sont en première
ligne
pour aider ces familles:
les services
de la préfecture,
le département,
nos pompiers,
nos forces de l'ordre,
les bénévoles ainsi que tous
les élus locaux.
Leur solidarité mérite
notre reconnaissance
la plus profonde.
Autour de Montreuil-sur-Mer,
des dizaines
de comités de quartier
sont transformés
en îlots isolés,
presque coupés du monde.
C'est la même
désolation à Saint-Omer
et dans bien d'autres communes.
Au total, ce sont plus de 250
communes touchées
par les inondations.
On imagine déjà le coût
de reconstruction colossal
qui dépassera de loin
les capacités financières
de ces communes déjà éprouvées.
A cela s'ajoute
une catastrophe agricole.
L'attention portée
par le gouvernement
et par le président
à cette crise
ne fait aucun doute,
mais cette attention doit
surtout être la marque
d'une réponse rapide
et efficace à la détresse
de nos concitoyens.
Mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, face
à cette urgence,
et au-delà de la reconnaissance
de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle,
quelles mesures
immédiates et futures
sont envisagées pour soutenir
nos concitoyens,
les collectivités,
les agriculteurs
et les entreprises?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Merci.
Monsieur le député Tellier,
je veux saluer effectivement
et vous remercier
pour vos propos
à destination
des services déconcentrés
de l'Etat, des préfets,
des conseillers départementaux,
de tous les élus locaux.
Je suis solidaire de vos propos.
Je vais vous rappeler
ce que nous faisons,
comme je viens
de le dire à plusieurs
de vos collègues.
C'est bien sûr cet arrêté
et les 50 millions d'euros.
S'il faut plus,
on travaillera dessus,
mais il faut d'abord
un diagnostic
et consommer
ces 50 millions
d'euros avant de demander plus.
On n'oublie personne.
Vous avez parlé
des agriculteurs,
des élus locaux, des entreprises.
Tous sont sinistrés
aujourd'hui,
on en est conscients
et vous pouvez compter
sur moi sur le fait
qu'on va travailler
sur ce retour
d'expérience
pour être toujours
meilleurs au service
des populations
que je viens de citer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Amard
pour La France Insoumise.
- Gabriel Amard: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, samedi,
à Lyon, une cinquantaine
de membres
de l'extrême droite
néonazie ont attaqué
une conférence
de Palestine 69
après avoir déambulé
plus d'une heure
dans les rues
avec des barres de fer.
Je voudrais
avoir ici une pensée
pour les victimes de cette attaque
d'une grande lâcheté.
Une des personnes
présentes dira
aux services
de police avoir reçu
des coups de barre de fer.
Elle en ressortira
avec 15 jours d'ITT.
Au total, 7 blessés.
Dans la même soirée,
quatre étudiants d'une école
d'ingénieurs
ont été blessés
et une jeune fille
a été poursuivie
par un groupuscule.
Dès lors, nous avons vu
sur Telegram
des protagonistes
revendiquer
leurs actes.
Je voudrais dire
ici solennellement
notre colère.
Pendant que vous prépariez
la marche
avec madame Le Pen,
des militants d'extrême droite
s'organisaient pour cibler
des personnes âgées
et des jeunes.
30 novembre 2022,
6 décembre 2022,
9 mai 2023, trois courriers
à propos d'agressions équivalentes
restés tous sans réponse.
Comment 50 militants encagoulés
et armés ont-ils pu déambuler près
d'une heure
dans les rues
sans être appréhendés?
Ce sont au moins
six agressions
en trois ans qui ont été
rendues publiques
et on ne parle pas des autres.
Qu'attendez-vous pour engager
des dissolutions
de certains groupuscules?
Prenez-vous
l'engagement de fermer
les locaux de ces associations?
Agissez, madame
la Première ministre.
Nous n'acceptons pas
que nos concitoyens soient
attaqués sur la base
de leur couleur
de peau,
de leurs croyances
ou de leurs convictions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran:
Monsieur le député,
nous condamnons
avec la plus grande fermeté
les exactions commises
par ce groupuscule d'extrême
droite à Lyon.
La justice de notre pays
est saisie.
Au moins une arrestation
a été faite.
Une enquête va avoir lieu.
Elle permettra
d'avoir des réponses.
Notre main ne tremblera pas.
Nous luttons
contre la violence,
contre la violence
de l'ultradroite,
nous luttons aussi
contre la violence
de l'ultragauche
quand elle existe.
Dans votre question,
qui aurait presque pu entraîner
un consensus,
vous vous êtes permis
de pointer du doigt
la manifestation,
en corrélant
les actes commis
par ce groupe d'ultradroite
à la manifestation
contre l'antisémitisme
en disant
"Pendant que vous défiliez
avec madame
Le Pen".
Vous luttez
contre l'extrême droite?
Arrêtez de la faire monter.
Vous faites peur aux Français.
Dimanche,
à la manifestation à laquelle
vous avez refusé
de participer,
des habitants
de Grenoble sont venus
me voir en nous disant
qu'ils hésitaient
à voter pour madame Le Pen.
Ayez conscience
des atrocités racontées
par monsieur David Guiraud
qui a inventé
le révisionnisme avant l'heure!
Monsieur Mélenchon
fait beaucoup
de mal à notre pays
et à la cohésion nationale!
Il fait monter constamment
l'extrême droite!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Vincent Thiébaut
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Vincent Thiébaut:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé.
En juillet 2020,
le gouvernement s'est engagé
à revaloriser
les carrières en signant
le Ségur de la santé.
Contrairement
aux engagements nationaux,
les surcoûts
salariaux résultant
de l'application
de ces mesures
ne sont que partiellement
compensés
et ils mettent
en difficulté financière
les établissements de santé,
en particulier
les centres hospitaliers.
Dans la région
Grand Est, si les CHU
et les centres hospitaliers
en santé mentale
sont globalement
en situation d'équilibre,
il en est tout autre
pour les centres hospitaliers
qui portent l'essentiel
du déficit régional.
Ils représentent deux tiers
des établissements
de la région et portent
94% du déficit.
Cette situation s'est donc
largement dégradée
entre 2021 et 2022.
Le déficit des établissements
a été multiplié
par 16.
Pour le centre
hospitalier de Haguenau,
qui a été en situation
d'équilibre financière,
il est aujourd'hui
déficitaire
depuis 2021.
La situation se dégrade.
Le déficit est passé à 6
millions d'euros
en 2022, et le déficit
de cette année pourrait
être de 15 millions d'euros.
L'activité reste
équivalente au niveau
des actes de santé
par rapport à 2019.
Le sous-financement
pèse lourdement
sur ces centres hospitaliers.
Que prévoyez-vous
pour pallier ces déficits
et pour la tenue
des engagements
de compensation
des mesures prises
pour ces établissements
essentiels
pour notre territoire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Monsieur le député,
vous soulignez la situation
financière difficile
de très nombreux
hôpitaux de ce pays,
et il serait vain
et dérisoire de tenter
quelque déni que ce soit.
La situation financière
de très nombreux hôpitaux
est très tendue.
Elle l'est à la fois
structurellement
et conjoncturellement.
Vous avez évoqué l'inflation.
Structurellement,
vous l'avez très justement dit,
nous avons des situations
hétérogènes
entre les hôpitaux
universitaires
de Strasbourg,
qui étaient l'an dernier
à 10 millions d'excédents,
et des établissements
comme l'hôpital
de Haguenau,
qui a vu son déficit se creuser.
C'est pour répondre
structurellement
à cette situation
que nous avons engagé
le refinancement de l'hôpital.
Un CHU, une clinique
privée et un hôpital
plus local,
le financement
ne peut pas être le même.
C'est pourquoi
nous avons décidé
d'avoir trois briques
de financement:
une sur l'apport en termes
de santé publique
et de responsabilité
populationnelle,
l'autre sur la tarification
à l'activité,
et la troisième notamment
pour les hôpitaux universitaires.
C'est ainsi que nous ferons
face
à cette situation.
Je voudrais
souligner
que nous avons aussi
une inquiétude particulière
sur l'inflation.
Je suis en contact
permanent
avec les fédérations,
que ce
soit de l'hospitalisation
publique
ou privée,
le gouvernement
ne laissera pas dans l'impasse
les hôpitaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Guy Bricout
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Guy Bricout:
En mars dernier,
ma circonscription
était touchée
par une double annonce
aux conséquences lourdes:
deux sites majeurs
de l'agroalimentaire
ont décidé de fermer
leurs unités
de production,
une entreprise de 120 emplois
et une autre usine de 120 emplois.
Ces fermetures ont eu
un retentissement important
au niveau des médias et un impact
social considérable
dans une région
qui connaît un niveau
de chômage très élevé.
En milieu rural,
chaque usine qui ferme
est un déchirement.
Dans le Cambrésis,
la mobilisation
de l'ensemble des acteurs
a été exemplaire.
Nous avons eu
de nombreux contacts
et vous vous êtes déplacé
trois fois.
Je vous en remercie.
J'ai pu apprécier
votre fermeté à l'égard
des entreprises.
Votre action a amorcé
une dynamique permettant d'aboutir
à une nouvelle dynamique.
Depuis mars,
après une réunion
avec les services
préfectoraux,
nous avons identifié
les entreprises éligibles.
Cette politique
est très prisée
des industriels
et les incite à investir.
En accord
avec Nestlé,
vous vous étiez engagé
à ce que le site Buitoni
soit repris avant le 31
décembre,
mais on est toujours
loin d'une annonce
à la réalisation effective.
Qu'en est-il
de l'avenir de ce site,
tant en ce qui concerne
les salariés
que l'immobilier?
Une usine vide
est un drame
pour un territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Monsieur le député, comme vous,
en mars dernier,
nous avons été frappés
par deux coups
de tonnerre qui ont affecté
votre territoire,
l'annonce de la fermeture
d'une première usine,
puis la fermeture
de l'usine Buitoni.
Nous avons agi
en collaboration
avec les élus
pour aller
dans trois directions.
D'abord,
une pression maximale
sur les entreprises
pour qu'elles remplissent
leurs exigences sociales.
Les deux PSE ont été
signés à l'unanimité
des organisations
syndicales
des deux entreprises.
Ensuite, dynamiser
le territoire, investir
dans le territoire
via un dispositif
qui a permis d'identifier
un certain nombre
de projets qui vont créer près
de 200 emplois industriels
dans votre territoire.
Enfin, la recherche
d'un repreneur
pour chacun des sites.
Fin août, une entreprise belge
a annoncé investir 350 millions
d'euros pour créer 350
emplois sur l'usine
de la sucrerie.
Hier, l'entreprise Nestlé
a annoncé entrer
en négociation exclusive
avec une entreprise italienne,
le champion italien
des pizzas surgelées.
Pour ceux qui n'aiment pas
l'entreprise
sur ces bancs
et pour ceux qui détestent
l'Europe, nous avons de grandes
entreprises européennes
qui choisissent la France
et votre territoire.
La France est aujourd'hui
attractive.
Elle attire des capitaux
et des entrepreneurs
qui souhaitent
bénéficier de la qualité
des employés français
et françaises.
Dans cinq ans,
on aura créé
plus de 450 emplois
industriels
grâce à ces trois actions.
C'est autant
d'emplois industriels
qui avaient été détruits les 10
années précédentes.
Cette politique
porte des résultats.
Pour finir sur une note
légère, on fera
des frites belges
et des pizzas italiennes.
C'est mieux que l'inverse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Thierry Frappé.
- Thierry Frappé:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Monsieur le ministre,
suite à un avis donné
par le gouvernement,
le Sénat a voté
la suppression
de l'AME, proposant
son remplacement par l'aide
médicale d'urgence.
Nous nous réjouissons
d'un tel vote,
mais aussi
du réveil inespéré
de nos collègues des Républicains.
Les LR se trouvent
une nouvelle identité
dans le programme
de Marine Le Pen.
Depuis 2012, cela fait
plus de 10 ans...
Cela fait plus de 10
ans que Marine
Le Pen propose
la suppression de l'AME
pour la remplacer par l'aide
médicale d'urgence.
Cette proposition
est enfin adoptée.
Nous savons
l'instrumentalisation
autour de ce débat.
Mes chers collègues,
la France se doit d'aider
les personnes
dont l'état de santé
est en danger immédiat,
mais la France
ne doit pas devenir
une terre d'accueil
pour les maux du quotidien.
Comment pouvez-vous
ou pouvons-nous expliquer
à certains
de nos concitoyens
que des étrangers
ont accès aux soins
alors qu'eux ne peuvent se payer
certains services
de santé?
Monsieur le ministre,
votre texte
sur l'immigration
sera dans chambre
dans les prochaines semaines.
Ma question est la suivante:
allez-vous, oui
ou non, revenir
sur ce vote de sagesse
du Sénat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Monsieur le député,
nous n'avons
décidément pas la même
conception du monde,
de la nation
et de la République.
L'AME, l'aide médicale d'Etat,
ce n'est pas, contrairement
à ce que vous dites,
le même panier
de soin
que nos compatriotes
ne pourraient pas se payer.
C'est un dispositif,
sans doute
le plus suivi en termes
de dépenses publiques,
avec 1,2 milliard
parfaitement suivi
et connu.
Il n'y a dans l'AME,
pas le premier rapport
intermédiaire rendu
par Patrick Stefanini,
aucune espèce d'effet
d'attractivité
en matière d'immigration.
Là où nous n'avons pas la même
conception
du monde,
c'est que quand on est malade,
il ne suffit pas
d'être dans une situation
d'urgence
pour que la République puisse
vous soigner.
Nous n'aurions
jamais intérêt
à ce que ces personnes
se rendent
toutes à l'hôpital.
Nous avons intérêt
à ce que, en termes
de prévention notamment
des maladies infectieuses,
de la pneumologie,
à ce que la médecine
de ville prenne
toute sa part
dans la prise
en charge des malades.
Donc, non,
je suis au regret
de vous dire
que le gouvernement
a très clairement
dit
qu'il n'était pas favorable
à l'aide médicale d'urgence.
Tout sujet peut
être évidemment discuté.
L'AME fait l'objet d'une mission.
Nous en discuterons.
Ne confondons pas un texte
sur l'immigration
est une question
de santé publique.
- Thierry Frappé:
Monsieur le ministre,
vous l'avez rappelé,
le budget des hôpitaux publics
s'annonce être en difficulté
pour l'année 2024
avec l'inflation.
La suppression de l'AME
représenterait
une économie de 1,2
milliard d'euros.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Monsieur le député,
vous avez manifestement
une vision
de la nation
que je ne partage pas
et une méconnaissance
complète du système.
Si nous supprimons
l'AME,
c'est tout un tas
de dépenses qui reviennent
dans le budget des hôpitaux.
Ce serait
très préoccupant
pour les hôpitaux.
L'AME est le dispositif
le plus protecteur
pour nos hôpitaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Sandrine Rousseau.
- Sandrine Rousseau:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de la Justice.
Il n'a pas l'air d'être là!
Aujourd'hui,
dans l'atmosphère feutrée
des instances
européennes se discutent
les termes d'une
directive sur la lutte
des violences faites aux femmes.
Comme vous l'avez
compris par ma collègue
Francesca Pasquini,
la France fait obstacle
à l'intégration
du viol dans le texte.
Pourtant,
en France, 1 femme
toutes les 7 minutes
est concernée.
En France, 99% des viols ne seront
jamais sanctionnés.
L'impunité
des crimes commis
par les hommes
sur le corps des femmes
et des enfants,
c'est le patriarcat.
Comprenez-vous
la colère des femmes?
La loi française telle
qu'elle est écrite suppose
que les femmes
sont toutes et
tout le temps a priori
consentantes.
Il faut qu'il y ait
menace, surprise
ou contraintes pour que la justice
puisse éventuellement statuer.
La France doit entrer
dans le 21e siècle.
Le viol est un acte sexuel
sans consentement.
Pouvez-vous affirmer
que la position
de la France
est de se poser,
comme la Hongrie
de Viktor Orban,
à ce que le viol
soit un acte non consenti?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la ministre
en charge
des relations hommes-femmes.
- Bérangère Couillard:
Je voudrais rappeler
que la législation
française est l'une
des plus répressives d'Europe.
Elle réprime les crimes
de viol de 15 ans
de prison jusqu'à
réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité s'agissant
des faits aggravés.
L'absence de consentement
de la victime
est au coeur
de notre définition juridique.
Les critères, violence,
contrainte, menace
ou surprise, servent justement
à caractériser l'absence
de consentement de la victime
à la relation sexuelle.
Je vous rappelle
que le viol
n'a pas de définition
à ce jour
et que la Commission
européenne ne propose
que deux critères:
la menace de la violence,
ni la violence définie
la contrainte,
ni la surprise.
Si on intègre l'article
5 à la directive,
il y a un risque majeur de voir
la directive entièrement annulée,
et donc toutes ces avancées.
Vous ne précisez pas
non plus que vous défendez
une position
qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
des associations féministes.
Beaucoup d'entre
elles craignent
la modification de la définition.
Une femme peut
avoir dit oui
et ne pas être consentante.
Une femme peut
ne pas avoir dit
non et ne pas être consentant.
Nous devons
continuer à lutter
contre les violences sexuelles.
Depuis 4 ans,
il y a une meilleure prise
en charge, notamment
le nombre d'affaires
de viol ou d'agressions
sexuelles
qui ont été signalés au parquet.
Les plaintes
sont passées de 20.000
à 40.000 entre 2017 et 2021.
Le nombre de condamnations
pour viol
a augmenté de près de 40%
sur la même période.
Soyez assurée
de notre détermination.
Preuve en est, la France
est à l'initiative
de cette directive.
- Sandrine Rousseau:
Pour les seules 0,6%
de condamnations
des viols en France...
Nous qui sommes sans passé,
les femmes,
nous qui n'avons pas d'histoire
depuis...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Vous n'avez plus la parole.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Dunoyer
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Philippe Dunoyer: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Depuis près d'un an,
les Etats indépendantistes
et non indépendantistes
se réunissent pour décrire
et définir l'avenir
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Comme l'a souligné
le président
de la République le 26
juillet dernier,
il n'est pas question
de revenir
sur les acquis
des accords de Nouméa
et de Matignon
qui ont permis de bâtir
la paix.
Ils sont notre héritage,
un exemple
pour le monde,
un exemple français,
un exemple calédonien.
Ces accords, aujourd'hui,
il nous faut
les poursuivre.
Ils sont nés dans le sang
d'une guerre civile
qui n'a pas dit son nom.
Ils sont nés
du courage de leaders
qui ont su braver
leur propre corps.
Ils sont nés d'un Etat qui a su
se montrer innovant
et impartial.
Ils ont inventé
un chemin
qu'il nous faut poursuivre
dans le respect
de l'esprit du résultat
des référendums.
Une part de la sensibilité
indépendantiste
n'est pas présente
autour de la table
malgré les efforts engagés
par le gouvernement,
récemment encore dans le cadre
des réunions initiées.
Nous avons pris
l'initiative d'engager
il y a quelques semaines
un dialogue
entre formations
politiques calédoniennes.
Tous les groupes
indépendantistes
ont accepté d'y participer.
Cette dynamique calédonienne
pourrait encourager certains
à reprendre les discussions
avec l'Etat.
Le dernier maître mot,
c'est le consensus.
L'ère des actes
unilatéraux
est derrière nous.
Les statuts imposés
dans les années 80
nous ont conduit au chaos.
Le consensus
est le seul chemin
qui vaille.
Face aux difficultés
et au temps contraint,
comment le gouvernement
entend-il poursuivre
ses efforts de dialogue
pour favoriser l'émergence
d'un projet d'avenir partagé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député Philippe Dunoyer,
depuis plusieurs mois,
le président
de la République
et le gouvernement
s'emploient à créer
les conditions
d'un travail serein
et constructif
avec les acteurs politiques
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Alors que le processus
politique prévu
par l'accord
de Nouméa est arrivé
à son terme,
et que les Calédoniens
ont choisi
de demeurer français,
ce travail est la condition
indispensable
pour bâtir l'avenir
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Comme vous l'avez
dit, cela passe
par un dialogue avec tous:
indépendantistes
et non-indépendantistes,
dans toutes leurs composantes.
C'est dans cet esprit
que j'ai reçu l'ensemble
des délégations
politiques calédoniennes
à Matignon début septembre.
Je veux saluer l'esprit
de responsabilité
qui a présidé
aux derniers échanges
sur le projet
d'accord proposé
par le gouvernement.
Les travaux doivent
se poursuivre
pour parvenir à un accord
politique d'ici
la fin d'année,
conformément à l'objectif fixé
par le président de la République.
C'est pour cela que le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer
Gérald Darmanin
se rendra à nouveau
en Nouvelle-Calédonie fin
novembre.
Nous souhaitons et oeuvrons
à la participation active
de tous les acteurs
politiques représentatifs
pour définir l'avenir
institutionnel
du territoire.
Un accord doit
permettre de régler
des questions
aussi importantes
que la citoyenneté
calédonienne,
le dégel du corps électoral,
l'autodétermination,
le statut et les institutions.
Plus largement,
un accord permettra d'offrir
des perspectives à l'ensemble
des Calédoniens,
et je pense en particulier
à la jeunesse calédonienne.
S'il peut fixer
des bases nouvelles,
le futur accord s'inscrira
dans la continuité
des précédents.
Les accords de Matignon
et de Nouméa
sont des acquis historiques.
L'Etat y est attaché,
comme les acteurs politiques
calédoniens.
Ces accords ont été
rendus possibles
par la volonté commune
de bâtir un avenir
dans la paix civile
et par le rôle impartial joué
par l'Etat.
Les mêmes conditions
peuvent et doivent
être réunies aujourd'hui.
C'est le sens de l'action
de mon gouvernement.
Dans ce contexte,
monsieur le député Dunoyer,
je veux saluer votre entrée
en mobilisation
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie,
et vous pouvez compter
sur l'engagement
sans faille
de mon gouvernement
pour bâtir ce projet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Pierre Vatin.
- Pierre Vatin: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à madame la Première ministre.
J'y associe notre collègue
Yannick Mader.
Madame la Première
ministre, je voudrais
vous parler
des tickets-restaurant.
Une fois encore,
je ne suis pas certain
que les Français
qui travaillent puissent
vous comprendre.
Alors que vous allez
mettre fin
à une mesure
de justice sociale
parce qu'elle
est provisoire,
alors qu'il y a tant de mesures
provisoires
que la grogne est permanente.
Pourtant, il s'agit
d'une mesure
qui ne coûte rien
au budget de la nation.
Il s'agit d'une
mesure qui facilite
la vie de nos compatriotes
qui travaillent
et qui bénéficient d'avantages
des tickets-restaurant payés
par leur employeur
et par eux-mêmes.
Vous leur avez permis
d'élargir à l'ensemble
de l'alimentation
les achats au moyen
des tickets-restaurant.
Cela avait un avantage
sur leur pouvoir d'achat.
Ca coûte toujours
moins cher de préparer
un repas à la maison
que de l'acheter prêt.
Malheureusement, c'est fini.
Quel est le fondement
de cette décision
que mes collègues
Les Républicains
et moi-même ne comprenons pas?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député,
par respect
pour cet hémicycle
et ce qu'il représente,
je ne vais pas me mettre
à chanter.
Vous m'interrogez sur le titre
de tickets-restaurant
qui a été créé en 1967
et qui bénéficie aujourd'hui
à 5 millions de salariés,
que les employeurs
et salariés se sont pleinement
appropriés,
que l'Etat soutient,
car les exonérations
de prélèvement
sur les contributions
des employeurs est à peu près
à 1,5 milliard d'euros
par an.
Lorsqu'une sénatrice a,
l'année dernière,
lors de l'examen du projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat,
proposé un amendement
permettant d'étendre
ce dispositif
aux produits
qui ne sont pas directement
consommables,
le gouvernement l'a donc soutenue.
Le gouvernement
a engagé une réforme
de ce ticket-restaurant
pour le moderniser
et le dématérialiser,
pour le rendre
plus simple
pour les restaurateurs
et pour le sécuriser
entre les mains
des salariés.
Le corps
de votre question,
c'est la prolongation
de la capacité
à utiliser
les tickets-restaurant
pour des biens
qui ne sont pas immédiatement
consommables.
Je voudrais préciser
que c'est l'amendement
de la sénatrice
qui a borné ce dispositif
au 31 décembre 2023.
Je veux ensuite
m'interroger
sur le fait que,
parmi les 10.000 amendements
qui ont été déposés sur les textes
financiers cet automne,
aucun ne visait
la prolongation
de ce dispositif.
Je veux aussi
vous rassurer
en vous disant
que Bruno Le Maire
et Olivia Grégoire
ont engagé des discussions
avec les restaurateurs
et les représentants
des salariés
et des employeurs
pour que cette question,
à laquelle
le gouvernement
est très attaché,
trouve la réponse
la plus appropriée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Pierre Vatin:
Monsieur le ministre,
je trouve
que votre réponse
est bien alambiquée pour une chose
extrêmement simple
pour nos concitoyens.
C'est encore un coup porté
au pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Le nombre de tickets
perdus va augmenter
à cause de votre déficit
de connexion
avec la vie des Français.
Il aurait été simple
de reprendre l'amendement
de la sénatrice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Claudia Rouaux.
- Claudia Rouaux:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
la Bretagne, première région
agricole de France,
se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans une impasse.
Collectivités régionales,
syndicats agricoles,
manifestations
d'agriculteurs
comme ce jour à l'esplanade
des Invalides
à Paris, tous
vous ont fait part
de leurs inquiétudes
concernant l'insuffisance
de financement de mesures
agro-environnemental
et climatiques.
De nombreux
agriculteurs bretons
se sont engagés
vers une transition
agroécologique soutenue
par la collectivité régionale,
autorité de gestion
qui n'a jamais refusé
aucun dossier.
Malgré un cahier
des charges
de plus en plus exigeant,
2000 exploitations bretonnes
sont dans l'incertitude.
Leur demande risque
d'être rejetée
ou diminuée.
Pourtant,
1 milliard
de plus sur le budget
agriculture
dans le cadre du PLF 2024.
Comment expliquer une baisse de 65
millions d'euros,
et 12 millions
en crédits de paiement?
Ces chiffres
sont en contradiction
avec la parole du président
de la République,
qui a promis
un quinquennat écologique,
et cela doit
inévitablement passer
par une transformation
du modèle agricole.
A la suite
de la présentation
de la planification
écologique,
il n'est pas envisageable
de revenir
sur des contrats
en cours et de laisser
sur le bord de la route
des exploitations agricoles
volontaristes dans la transition
agro-écologique.
Madame la Première
ministre,
si l'on ne finance pas
suffisamment
les MAEC, comment
les agriculteurs pourraient-ils
encore croire
en la parole publique?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Franck Riester.
- Franck Riester:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Le plan stratégique
national porte
une ambition
forte au service
de la transition
agro-écologique
de l'agriculture française.
Plusieurs dispositifs
concourent à l'atteinte
de cet objectif
et à la valorisation
des pratiques
vertueuses, du point
de vue de la préservation
de la biodiversité
et des ressources naturelles.
Ces dernières semaines,
les agriculteurs
qui se sont engagés
dans cette démarche vertueuse
ont exprimé
des inquiétudes,
notamment en Bretagne,
sur leur mise
en oeuvre de l'application
de la mesure.
Le paiement d'avance
des aides a été versé
sur le compte
des agriculteurs,
soit près de 3,64
milliards d'euros.
Les MAEC ont vocation
à être payés
à compter du premier
trimestre 2024.
Nous connaîtrons le besoin
précis seulement
après l'instruction
des dossiers MAEC
qui démarre après celle
des paiements directs.
Je tiens à rappeler
que la programmation 2015-2020
a été réalisée par l'Etat
et les régions.
L'exercice
de la programmation 2023
a été fait entre MAEC,
coprésidé
par l'Etat et les régions.
Nous sommes sur une volonté
collective,
dans l'exercice responsable
de priorisation
des besoins au regard
du diagnostic agro-environnemental
du territoire.
Je rappelle les 12,5
millions d'euros
de MAEC pour la région
Bretagne,
qui s'est déroulée
comme un moyen d'accompagner
les démarche vertueuse
des agriculteurs,
et qui sont à prendre en compte.
Vous pouvez compter
sur la mobilisation
la plus totale
du gouvernement
et de Marc Fesneau
afin qu'une solution
soit trouvée avec l'ensemble
des co-financeurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Claudia Rouaux:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
Il en va quand même du devenir
de l'agriculture
en Bretagne,
des enjeux écologiques,
mais aussi économiques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Emmanuel Fernandes.
- Emmanuel Fernandes:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Une question au ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Le Conseil constitutionnel
a récemment reconnu
pour la première
fois la protection
des générations
futures en affirmant
leur droit à vivre
dans un environnement sain.
Dans le dossier StocaMine,
le tribunal administratif
de Strasbourg a débouté
l'Etat en suspendant
les travaux
d'enfouissement définitif
de 42.000 tonnes de déchets
hautement toxiques
à 500 mètres
de la nappe phréatique.
Face à la nécessité
de remonter
à la surface les déchets dangereux
contenant amiante,
cyanure, arsenic
et autre poisons,
vous mentez et vous entravez.
Vous prétendez
que la protection
autour des déchets serait
prétendument étanche.
Votre collègue Olivier Becht ment
lorsqu'il affirme
que la seule alternative
serait un déstockage
à mains nues.
Vous mentez en disant
que le déstockage mettrait
des mineurs
dans des situations
bien plus pénibles.
Vous entravez
les experts indépendants
comme les entreprises
volontaires
en refusant l'accès à la mine.
Vous n'entretenez pas
suffisamment
les galeries et le puits.
Quand des associations
s'opposent
à vos méfaits, vous tentez
de les dissoudre.
Votre gouvernement
autoritaire vient
de subir une lourde défaite
avec l'annulation
par le Conseil d'Etat
de la dissolution
des Soulèvements de la Terre.
Gérald Darmanin
va pouvoir avaler
son terme délirant
d'"éco-terroristes",
né dans son imaginaire.
Combien de défaites
cinglantes devrez-vous
subir avant de prendre acte
que la seule solution raisonnable
et de déstocker la StocaMine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Fernandes, StocaMine
est une organisation
de stockage
de déchets dangereux.
Après de multiples analyses,
le gouvernement
a décidé en 2014
sous la présidence
de François Hollande
de faire extraire
les déchets
les plus susceptibles
d'avoir un impact sur la nappe
phréatique d'Alsace
et de confiner les autres déchets.
A son arrivée au ministère
de la Transition écologique,
Christophe Béchu
a réexaminé le dossier
en veillant à la plus grande
transparence
sur les informations
dont il disposait
et en organisant
de nombreuses réunions
avec les élus parlementaires
du territoire.
Le ministre a décidé
de confiner
la mine sans opération
de déstockage, s'appuyant
sur 134 études.
Confiner StocaMine
est une décision
qui s'impose à tous
pour trois raisons.
Le délai de confinement
minimale
est de 42 mois,
or, sous l'effet
de la pression,
les galeries se referment.
La mine deviendra
inaccessible dès 2027.
Deuxième raison:
il n'y a pas de possibilité
de mener de front
des travaux de confinement
et des opérations de déstockage.
Troisième raison:
déstocker
des déchets avant le confinement
ferait peser
un risque inacceptable
pour les personnels humains.
Le gouvernement
a donc travaillé
avec les élus locaux sur un plan
de confinement qui prévoit
des conditions
de réversibilité
du stockage en anticipant
un possible déploiement de futurs
techniques robotiques
de déstockage.
La loi de finances
pour 2024 garantie
le maintien en sécurité
du stockage
de ces déchets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le député, 2 secondes.
- Emmanuel Fernandes:
Vous ne maîtrisez visiblement
vraiment pas le sujet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Cécile Rilhac.
- Cécile Rilhac: Merci.
Mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'Economie
et des Finances.
De par ses applications,
le spatial
est aujourd'hui
fondamentalement stratégique
pour notre nation.
De fait, le spatiale
est devenu un outil majeur
de notre souveraineté.
Souveraineté technologique,
industrielle, stratégique
et militaire.
Sans le spatial,
la France et l'Europe perdraient
dans de nombreux domaines
leur autonomie vis-à-vis
des grandes puissances.
C'est le constat qui a conduit
les 22 Etats-membres
de l'Agence spatiale
européenne à conduire
un accord sur l'avenir
de l'Europe spatiale
à Séville.
Cet accord historique
marque le retour
au premier plan de la puissance
spatiale européenne,
l'occasion de souligner
le fabuleux travail
de nos ministères
et de nos agences spatiales.
En assurant un soutien
financier important
au programme Ariane 6,
les Etats européens
ont fait le choix
fort de préserver
notre accès
autonome à l'espace
pour la prochaine décennie.
Cet accord marque également
la volonté européenne
de renouer
avec l'exploration
en se dotant d'un premier
vaisseau cargo
qui lui permettra
d'ouvrir la voie
aux vols habités.
Enfin, cet accord réitère
l'engagement européen
pour l'observation de la Terre,
outil indispensable
pour mener à bien
nos engagements climatiques.
Ces nouvelles
perspectives amèneront
la France à repenser
sa stratégie
en la matière:
l'ouverture à la concurrence
des programmes
européens nous imposent
à soutenir davantage
nos acteurs français
en amont.
Aussi, monsieur
le ministre, pouvez-vous
nous préciser comment la France
entend tirer profit
de ces nouvelles
dispositions
et si le gouvernement
entend produire
un document de politique
spatiale nationale
pour accompagner
ces changements
et notre industrie?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot:
Madame la présidente,
madame la députée Cécile Rilhac,
chacun connaît ici
votre engagement
et votre expertise
sur ces sujets.
Aussi, je ne peux
que vous rejoindre,
quand vous saluez l'accord
qui a été trouvé
la semaine dernière
lorsque la France,
sous l'intention
de Bruno Le Maire,
l'Italie et l'Allemagne
se sont accordés
pour trouver un accord
qui constitue
un succès majeur
et un tournant décisif
pour l'Europe spatiale.
Avec la sécurisation du modèle
économique d'Ariane 6,
grâce à 340 millions d'euros
de subventions annuelles
pour les années
qui viennent
et grâce à 15
nouveaux lancements
qui viennent s'ajouter aux 27 déjà
contractualisés,
grâce ensuite
au soutien réaffirmé
à la nouvelle génération
des lanceurs, notamment
grâce à la mobilisation du plan
France 2030 voulu
il y a 2 ans
par le président
de la République qui consacre 1,5
milliard d'euros
à ses acteurs dont les deux tiers
doivent venir soutenir
des acteurs émergeant,
avec la confirmation
du rôle du centre
spatial guyanais
comme lieu de lancement
de classe mondiale
pour l'ensemble
des acteurs, à commencer
par Ariane 6, et puis
avec l'ambition
de réaffirmer
de faire de l'Europe
une puissance
d'exploration
avec un programme d'acquisition
de service cargo.
Vous voyez,
madame la députée,
sous l'autorité
de la Première ministre,
le gouvernement a veillé
à ce que l'Europe
des lanceurs soit relancée.
Cet effort vient
en complément du soutien
de la France à la constellation
Iris 2, constellation européenne,
qui va nous servir
à garantir
notre résilience en matière
de télécommunications,
car vous avez raison,
c'est bien
dans l'espace que se joue
une part importante
de notre souveraineté
technologique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.